[Music]
people think my destiny will always find
each other
[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie toss a
coin to your Witcher this is gonna be my
season 2 top 10 predictions video so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I will
be doing bonus videos for The Witcher
while we wait for episodes to come back
we already have a loose timeline for
when that's going to be so don't worry
I'll break it down to the video but
obviously spoiler warning for everything
from The Witcher Season 1 if you haven't
seen the episodes yet so starting with
number 10 the season 2 timeline will be
way more linear and even though all
three of them main leads Geralt ciri and
yennefer won't always be together at the
same time for the most part all the
storylines will be happening during the
same time period I think this comes as a
relief to most of you guys because on
the videos that I posted for The Witcher
Season one there was a lot of confusion
about where everybody was in the
timeline in any given episode they'll
probably be a couple more flashbacks
just for context because there's still
some things that happen in the past that
we don't have any answers about yet like
what happened to series parents Dooney
and pavetta they're lost at sea we need
to get a flashback to kind of explain
that maybe towards the end of season two
this season you all probably noticed
that the timelines were different for
each character though so series started
in present-day Geralt started a couple
years before she was born
and then Janna first timeline started a
couple of decades before that if it
wasn't clear even though the actress
that plays yennefer looks younger than
Henry Cavill in real life in the context
of the story yennefer of vengerberg is a
couple decades older than Geralt of
Rivia both mages and witcher's age much
slower than normal humans so Geralt is
around his 70s during the course of this
season
yennefer is around her 90s when they
meet for the first time in the books
really only follow the characters until
ciri is in her 20s so there's not a ton
of huge time jumps between the first
book in the last book because right now
ciri is supposed to be around 13 years
old if you played the games though the
games are meant to be a sequel to the
book story so the characters are all a
couple years older in the present-day of
the video games but there are a lot of
flashbacks during the video games too
either way the showrunner has already
confirmed that the season 2 timeline
will make way more sense and be way
easier to follow
number 9 talking about what's happening
at the beginning of the season since the
TV show already changed the way the
Geralt meets ciri and on the show this
peasant family lives right
two sodden hill where that big battle
was going on the next big thing that
they'll probably do as Geralt old the
man who saved him is travel through
sodden hill to get to care morhen in the
school of the wolf
that's where vesemir is where Garret was
raised and trained to be a Witcher if
you haven't read the books or you
haven't played the games there are
several different schools for witcher's
the school of the wolf is just one of
them initially he wanted to go there
because he was slowly dying from his
wounds but because he just found ciri
his child of surprise and the person
he's charged to protect it just makes
sense to go to care morhen because it's
way safer there number eight on the way
through sodden Hill - also probably try
to find yennefer there were a couple of
reasons why ciri said who's in affirm an
they met in the woods
even though ciri herself has never heard
yennefer of vengerberg name spoken out
loud she probably didn't even know she
existed - the last few episodes the
reason why she says her name though is
one probably because of her elder blood
powerful magic giving her visions and
dreams that she doesn't totally
understand
in the books series crazy powers give
her really dark dreams so she's probably
thinking to herself why do I keep
hearing this name yennefer in my head
and in my dreams who is this person that
I keep thinking about and to the more
practical reason for sending them
through sodden Hill on their way to the
school of the wolf is for story
progression it allows Geralt to try and
find out whether or not yennefer was
killed during the battle because
yennefer geralt and ciri probably won't
all be together for a good long while
most of Geralt story for the first half
of season two will probably just be him
in ciri together
Papa bless but number seven because we
are going to the school the wolf will
probably meet vesemir for the first time
on the show we didn't see his character
during season one because the closest we
got there was when we saw the flashbacks
of Geralt smother Vicente leaving him at
their doorstep so to speak if you've
been on Twitter the last couple of days
- you probably saw Mark Hamill was
tweeting about it ever since they
announced Netflix was doing a Witcher
series people were tweeting at Mark
Hamill that he should be vesemir he's
never read The Witcher books never
played the games so he has no idea what
the Witcher story is or who vesemir is
but as you can see he's totally down to
play him even the showrunner Lauren his
rich made it seem like she was going to
reach out to him so if his schedule
works out with their shooting days for
season 2 which is sometime next spring
we could totally see Mark Hamill
sameer if you're not familiar with the
character vesemir is just a much older
Witcher who taught Geralt and helps
teach ciri in the books so he's sort of
soft retired from regular Witcher
monster-hunting duties and spends most
of his time at the school the wolf is an
instructor speaking of which number six
big one ciri will probably begin
training to become a Witcher herself
pretty soon they changed the reason why
Geralt chose her as his child of
surprise from the books on the TV show
they made it seem like more of a
coincidence like okay I'll do the same
thing that you did and choose the law of
surprise and then he finds out that
they're pregnant but in the books Geralt
knows that series mother pavetta is
pregnant before he chooses the law of
surprise and in the books his hope was
that it would be a boy so that he could
train that boy to become another Witcher
because in the present day of the books
The Witcher order is slowly dying out
there was that line of dialogue earlier
in the season from yennefer where she
says there's so few wizards left in the
world why do I keep running into you all
of a sudden the reason why their order
is slowly dying out is because so few
children survive the trials that they go
through to become witcher's they go the
trial the grasses they take a bunch of
potions that give them their Witcher
mutations with their special powers
most kids wind up dying during that so
it's just a simple math equation you
have fewer new witcher's being minted
and older ones dying off or being killed
quicker and quicker so it's just rapidly
shrinking their order around the world
and even though they haven't really
talked about it part of Geralt implied
duty to the school of the wolf as a
Witcher is to help create more witchers
to sustain the order so even though ciri
is born a girl his goals still the same
he needs to create more witcher's so
because ciri belongs to him as child to
surprise and he has no use for an actual
child his main goal is basically just to
create a new witcher like okay here you
go
so even though his goals are very simple
all the ciri elder bloods stuff the
nilfgaard war emperor mir just make
things way more complicated for him and
you also notice in those flashbacks that
Geralt is about the same age as ciri
when his mother drops him off at the
school of the wolf so ciri is of a
proper age to begin training if you've
ever played the games - you see ciri
training in a flashback scene at the
very beginning of witcher 3 number 5
series elder blood is going to continue
to manaphy
itself in more weird ways freaking out
geralt and vesemir we've already seen
her use her abilities without trying
just completely hook out on these
brigands she has no control over them
she doesn't know anything about her
special bloodline so they'll need
someone like yennefer or trysts or
another mage to explain how serious
powers work what it all means and why
she's even more important now than she
was before because you have to remember
that even without the elder blood and
the special magical powers ciri is
already a really important person
because she's the rightful heir to the
throne of sintra and through her
grandmother's marriage to this guy to
the Skellig and that's not even the end
of it through her father Dooney she's
also heir to a much larger territory
which we can't really talk about without
getting into spoilers so if you have
read the books or played the games
please do not post spoilers for series
father due knee number 4
since yennefer took off after the Battle
of sodden Hill she probably won't be
around to help Geralt with ciri probably
at least until the middle or near the
end of season 2 depending on how fast
they move through the timeline but
univer is the most qualified person to
help train ciri in magic because she is
one of the most powerful magical people
on the show she just doesn't understand
how her powers work most of this
probably won't happen till after Geralt
realizes what's going on with ciri
because he's only just met her here he
hasn't seen her use any of her powers or
anything like that
and no one's told him about her special
powers he's very learned is a Witcher
but he only has rudimentary knowledge of
magic like he can cast all those signs
that you saw during the season like this
is the art side the one that he uses
during the butcher of lavich and fight
when he blasts them back with his
telekinetic force there's the Ignace
sign the Quinn the AXI the eared ensigns
but that's pretty much the extent of his
magical knowledge so that's why you need
someone like yennefer trysts to come in
and teach ciri actual magic number three
will probably meet emperor mirror
officially in nilfgaard for the first
time we've only heard about him on the
show so far but if you've read the books
please don't post spoilers about emperor
mirror he's the one who ordered the
attack on sodden hill he's the one that
frin Gila keeps referring to as the
white flame quote-unquote in the last
few episodes he al stood the usurper
from his throne and he's been reforming
nofe cardian politics and cleaning house
since retaking his throne
couple of years he's also the one who
ordered Kay here this character here to
bring ciri to him at the beginning of
the season when you think about all the
stuff he's responsible for this season
he does kind of come off like a villain
but he does have a good reason for doing
what he's doing that we might not find
out about till a little bit later but
because it's meant to play like a big
reveal like I said please no spoilers
about Emperor Amir in the comments
number two we'll learn more about the
mage vilgum forts who we saw in the
final few episodes of season 1 he seemed
like he was fighting against nilfgaard
on the side of the brotherhood of
sorcerers they kept referring to how
battle hungry who was and how much time
he'd spent making war he had that big
fight with Kay here even though he lost
I know a lot of people were upset about
that because Villa forts is way more
powerful than that in the books he would
have never lost to Kay here but he seems
like he's a good character fighting for
the Brotherhood but then there's this
last scene with him that we saw in the
finale that's super important because
like he said supposed to be fighting to
defeat nilfgaard then why does he
brutally kill one of his fellow mages
from the Brotherhood when he asked for
his help if it wasn't clear Villa forts
is killing one of the good guys here
that's why you see all these other dead
nilfgaardian soldiers around him
help me bro they just bludgeons him to
death there's a very important reason
why he's probably doing that and why it
seems like he may have flipped sides
during the battle but maybe wants to get
rid of the Brotherhood like think about
the other mage they came for yennefer as
a saboteur within their ranks while she
was on the tower we'll learn more about
what's going on with him next season but
he's a hugely important character in the
books in number one finally we also
learn how all these disparate events
during season 1 are connected in how
ciri is at the center of everything the
disappearance of her mother and father
Dooney and pavetta the fall of sintra
the nilfgaardian wars the Battle of
sodden Hill Ville go for its Emperor
Amir the dryads and the elder blood it's
all connected and ciri is at the center
of everything the showrunner said that
they had about a 7 season plan I'm
expecting them to make it to at least
four or five so I don't think that
they're gonna reveal all these things
and how everything is connected by the
end of season 2 so please don't post
spoilers if you have read the books or
played the games if you want to find
answers to all those questions though
you can read the books and play the
games while you wait for season 2 to get
here it's all in there
the games don't cover everything from
the books they're kind of meant to be a
sequel to the book story but they do
have a bunch of flashbacks and big
reveals about stuff that happened during
the books the games are just really cool
either way they're just really badass
games right now the season 2 release
date won't be until 2021 but I'm
assuming it'll be summer 2021 or later
because the Game of Thrones prequel
series will probably release in spring
2021 and I don't think that Netflix
wants The Witcher to have to compete
with that so expect them to plan around
the Game of Thrones prequel which will
probably run from April to June I'll
keep doing bonus videos through the next
week or so so leave all your video
requests and big questions and
predictions for season 2 on the video
everyone click here for all my Witcher
Netflix episode videos and Easter eggs
and click here for my Mandalorian season
2 teaser video in Easter eggs thank you
so much for watching everybody toss
you
Oh